it's hard to put a good game down but
sometimes that leads to bigger problems
a Russian man is suing bethesda over
what he claims is an addiction to
Fallout 4 over playing the game has
caused him to lose his job and wife so
he's asking for 5,000 rubles that's
seven thousand US dollars for emotional
distress the 28 year old man downloaded
fallout 4 after seeing it advertised and
he meant to only play for a few evenings
this led to skipping work and ignoring
his friends according to Russian website
RT there was no precedent for this case
in the country the man also told the
site if I knew that this game could have
become so addictive I would have become
a lot more wary of it I would not have
bought it or it would have left it until
I was on holiday or until the new year
holidays you might be a little hesitant
to play fallout 4 after that but we did
name in our number 6 game of the year
you can check out the full list at
gamespot.com / game of the year and when
we learn more about the case you'll
already be in the right place